if there's one thing they do right in
cuba it's healthcare and it may be
surprising to see just how much the
cuban healthcare system is thriving cuba
has the best
healthcare system in the entire area one
thing that is well established in the
global health community is the strength
of the cuban national health system
despite being a poor country cuba has
one of the strongest health care systems
in the world and in many respects much
better than the us and so now after all
these years one thing is clear
the cuban people have free universal
health care
es
conditioner
[Music]
a
since the 1959 communist revolution in
cuba there have been hundreds of
newspaper articles magazine features
news segments and documentaries
celebrating the marvel of its healthcare
system even president castro talks
openly about cuba's long list of
economic mistakes
but everyone approves of at least one
investment the government has made in
free universal health care all the
independent health organizations in the
world
and even our own cia believes that the
cubans have a pretty good health system
it's all part of an elaborate propaganda
campaign that disguises the reality of
cuban health care it's clinics like most
routine supplies like antibiotics
bandages syringes and oxygen and in some
cases running water
their hallways are often occupied by
ailing patients because there aren't
enough doctors to treat their most basic
needs and its hospitals are unsanitary
and decrepit cuban healthcare is exactly
what you'd expect in a country
impoverished by communism the only thing
that's changed is because of social
media and the kova 19 pandemic the
government's propaganda facade has
finally started to shatter and yet in
2021 some journalists were falling for
the claim that the cuban government had
set the model for its response to kovit
we begin today's show looking at how
cuba has successfully fought the
pandemic
since last year only about 440 cubans
have died from coven 19 giving the
island one of the lowest death rates per
capita in the world three months after
that broadcast cubans took to the
streets and to twitter and facebook in
part to call attention to what the
pandemic had actually meant for the
island nation's healthcare system in the
past few weeks cuba has experienced its
biggest spike in coronavirus cases yet
at the same time it is getting harder to
find food on the island
the protests that swept across cuba the
largest in decades stunned the
communist-run government in the 15 years
since the release of michael moore's
documentary sicko which celebrated cuban
healthcare their only sin when it comes
to health care seems to be that they
don't do it for a profit everyday
citizens have been armed with
smartphones twitter instagram and
facebook empowering them to tell the
truth about what it's really like to
walk into a cuban hospital so when you
say that all you have to do to realize
the truth about the cuban healthcare
system is actually go to cuba well you
have the example of someone who did go
who was michael moore and he came up
with sico which obviously presents the
cuban healthcare system as a great
triumph i meant do not go on one of
those stage potemkin tours maria warlow
is an author analyst and the founder of
the cuba archive which promotes human
rights through research he went to a
facility that was prepared to receive
him that was part of this montage
you know clearly that wouldn't stand
today because you have so many videos
coming out i think from facilities in
cuba is that due to social media it's
due to social media and to telephones
people are you know it's almost daily
thing is it's mostly in spanish and
mostly you have to look for them but if
you go on youtube and i mean on facebook
it's daily daily people are posting this
so how did the caster regime's
propaganda machine manage to fool so
many for so long the answer lies with
cuba's foreign medical missions which
are teams of healthcare professionals
dispatched to provide emergency and
routine care to foreign countries
the first medical mission was sent to
algeria in 1963. after the fall of the
soviet union when the government lost
its major source of aid the program was
ramped up significantly as a source of
revenue for the impoverished nation the
cuban government has promoted the
missions as a humanitarian endeavor and
the demonstration of the community
spirit and selflessness that's central
to the communist project in his 1960
speech on revolutionary medicine the
marxist revolutionary che guevara said
that individualism must disappear in
cuba he recounted the story of a group
of physicians in havana who demanded
remuneration before going into the
country's rural areas to treat the sick
he dreamed of replacing them with a new
class of doctors drawn from the
peasantry who would run immediately and
with unreserved enthusiasm to help their
brothers
this will be a battle of solidarity
against selfishness is a fidel castro
quote inscribed on the wall at the
medical school in havana alongside a map
showing all of the places in the world
that the medical missions have served
cuba produces a lot of physicians in
this country and you know where they go
they go to poor countries around the
world doing a lot of good they become
known around the world as being one of
the most generous countries in providing
doctors and medical equipment to third
world countries
it's a big show the cubans get off the
airplane wearing their white jackets you
know after a long cross-atlantic flight
with their flags you know not even
doctors without borders that has an
amazing program has that kind of
propaganda behind them what fantastic
work the cuban doctors have done that
they should be nominated for a nobel
peace prize in 2021 for the nobel peace
prize for 2021 and i'm very happy to
nominate them
participated in the medical mission in
sierra leone in 2013 where healthcare
specialists from around the world came
to help contain the ebola epidemic the
members of the mission were told that
when they returned to cuba they would be
received as heroes and that the
government would give them each a new
car
a
dr rio says he did receive a stipend
that went to cover his living expenses
medical personnel from other countries
on the other hand were generously
compensated
[Music]
who is part of a medical mission in
venezuela and fled in 2015 points out
that host countries are paying for these
services and that the money is going to
the cuban government instead of the
doctors who are doing the work
they say
the myth of cuban physicians as selfless
healers started to fracture in 2000 when
two doctors from the mission in zimbabwe
slipped a note to an airline official
with a handwritten word kidnapped they
had denounced the castro regime and were
being brought back to cuba against their
will possibly to face jail time instead
they wound up in the u.s and were
granted political asylum in a 2020
report human rights watch said the cuban
medical missions violate doctors
fundamental rights including the right
to privacy freedom of expression and
association liberty and movement among
others they noted that many doctors feel
pressured to participate in the missions
and fear retaliation if they do not and
that governments that accept cuban
assistance that includes the abusive
conditions imposed by cuba risk becoming
complicit in human rights violations
it starts from the recruitment and how
it's done
that is not fair that it's not
transparent that does not tell the
doctors what conditions they're going to
face when they're when they go does not
give them an option to say i want this
or not or i agree to it or not to begin
with the employment is a problem but
then they're forced to leave their
families in cuba they cannot bring them
with them and if they abandon the
mission or they let's say they don't
want to continue anymore to be in the
mission they want to stay in brazil or
venezuela or south africa or whatever
they are prevented from going back to
cuba for at least eight years there's
specific laws that they could be put in
prison for years because they're
considered traitors for the past decade
the united states has encouraged cuban
doctors and nurses working outside cuba
to defect to the united states in 2006
the george w bush administration created
the cuban medical professional parole
program granting health care workers
stationed abroad permanent resident
status all they had to do was make it to
a u.s embassy over 7 000 medical workers
took advantage of the program
[Music]
is the president of the miami-based
solidarity without borders which helps
cuban doctors who have escaped
in 2014 the new york times op-ed page
published an editorial calling for an
end to the program american immigration
policy should not be used to exacerbate
the brain drain of an adversarial nation
it noted in other words the rights of
doctors to decide where and how to live
should be subordinate to what was best
for the cuban government
much
after the mission in sierra leone dr
rios was redeployed to a military base
in mexico one day he was sent with a
group of doctors to buy some phone cards
so they could connect with their
relatives back home he decided to make
his escape message
[Music]
[Music]
a
foreign dr rios found a job at a mexican
pharmacy to start saving money to pay a
coyote to bring him into the u.s
he was picked up by the border patrol
and taken to an immigrant detention
center for 42 days
[Music]
[Music]
in 2018 a group of cuban doctors who
defected from the medical mission sued
the pan-american health organization
which is part of the world health
organization for aiding in human
trafficking and for earning 75 million
in fees for acting as a middleman
organization
organization
protagonist
[Music]
[Music]
the medical missions are primarily a way
of selling cuban healthcare services
abroad but what's healthcare like for
those living on the island cuba quite
surprisingly has a very advanced
biopharma
industry unlike the rest of the
developing world there's no doctor
shortage in cuba we've seen wide
improvements of cuban health across the
population providing a kind of care
that's both personal
[Music]
[Music]
when defenders of human healthcare
acknowledge its deficiencies at all they
usually point the finger at the u.s
trade embargo which has been in place
since 1962. for decades cuba has heavily
invested in its medical and
pharmaceutical system in part because of
the six-decade-old
u.s embargo cubans tend to blame their
hardships on the u.s trade embargo one
of the biggest problems remains the
embargo of medicine from u.s
pharmaceutical companies but the
deplorable conditions in cuban hospitals
have more to do with a lack of basic
health care supplies which are readily
available from other countries such as
antibiotics and steroids human hospitals
also have a shortage of beds and
stretchers and some are without water
for six to 12 hours a day at the height
of the pandemic so what impact does the
embargo really have on cuban health care
medical products have been technically
exempt from the embargo since the
passage of the 1992 cuba democracy act
but the law does stipulate that u.s
companies need a license in order to
sell to cuba and critics are correct to
point out that this requirement adds red
tape to the process total u.s healthcare
products purchased by cuba from 2003 to
2021 averaged a mere 1.4 million dollars
annually in what should be a 50 to 100
million dollar market but it's not the
licensing process that accounts for such
paltry sales companies would gladly
obtain permission to sell their products
to cuba if they could earn enough money
to make it worth the effort cuba has a
severe foreign currency shortage because
it produces little in the way of goods
and services that the rest of the world
wants to buy
promoters of human healthcare often cite
the country's infant mortality rate as
evidence of its success
and yet the cubans are able to have a
lower infant mortality rate than the
united states cuba has similar life
expectancy and lower infant mortality
than the united states how's this
possible that an american infant is by
official statistics almost 50 percent
more likely to die than a cuban infant
wrote nicholas kristoff in a 2019 new
york times column that looked at one of
the most often repeated figures in
support of the claim that there's
something exceptional about cuba's
health care system while conceding that
the figure should be taken with a dose
of skepticism kristoff chose to
interpret them regardless in support of
his priors cuba has a medicare for all
that many americans dream about foreign
[Music]
cuba has a variety of strategies for
manipulating its infant mortality rate
such as seeing to it that fetuses less
likely to survive outside the womb never
get the chance there's significant
evidence that cuban doctors coerce women
into aborting fetuses shown to have
abnormalities after routine ultrasounds
we have to understand that the
physicians in cuba are a member of the
army and they have to meet certain
targets in terms of infant mortality and
if they don't meet those targets they
face penalties vincent calloso who's an
assistant professor of economics at
george mason university co-authored a
2018 paper arguing that cuba's low
infant mortality rate in part is a
result of misclassification using a
different indicator known as late fetal
deaths late fetal deaths are things that
happen before birth and early neonatal
deaths so in the first seven days that
means you reclassify the early seven day
thefts as late fetal deaths that way
they don't pop into the official
statistics and we can actually look at
statistics of how
their ratio of late fetal death to early
neonatal death are
for most western countries the ratio is
generally four to one six to one uh
whereas cuba is like an outlier where
it's 14 or 15 to one which is a clear
sign of this distorted set of incentives
so there is once you adjust for that you
find that cuba's infinite mortality rate
goes as high as doubles sometimes
increases by
half of what it is sometimes twice what
it is
despite reports early in the pandemic
that cuba was an outlier in its success
in combating covid cuba has
far surpassed the united states when it
comes to
covid19 and people surviving
[Music]
by august of 2021 the new york times was
reporting that cuba's healthcare system
was reeling with oxygen supplies running
low a shortage of syringes and
mortuaries and crematories overwhelmed
president miguel diaz-canel blamed the
u.s trade embargo hello
[Music]
[Music]
dr rios has three kids ages 7 12 and 16
still living in cuba and he's hoping to
bring them to the u.s
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
one